martin biron michel sauget stéphanie
grammond bonsoir
alors madame anglade un test de
leadership martin la mari bon petit
exclu du caucus votre journal c'est
fanny ce matin nous apprend qu'il ya eu
des plaintes pour harcèlement
psychologique
alors martine qu est ce qu on a aussi ce
soit parce que ça s'est fait par étape
ce soir là en fin de semaine ils ont
perdu
elle est monsieur barret toutes leurs
responsabilités et la voici qu on
l'exclût qu'est ce qui est arrivé entre
vendredi aujourd'hui il ya une gradation
moi aussi j'ai écrit et vendredi sur la
situation au parti et les rapports
difficiles de madame montpetit avec
beaucoup d'employés politique bon tout
ça fait partie du fameux tweet la
matraque de twitts à dire que madame
montpetit ans contredit un député gaétan
barrette sur twitter publiquement alors
là la crise a éclaté
madame anglade en apprend tous les jours
un peu plus sur marie mon petit je pense
que c'est pas la fin de l'histoire c'est
pas la fin des allégations alors là
c'était plus possible de la garder au
sein de son caucus pour get en barrettes
elle l'a aussi largué le ce matin je
l'écoutais avec paul arcand et
elle n'a pas dit qu'elle souhaitait le
revoir candidat à la prochaine élection
le plq aux mines croix sur la réforme
barrette monsieur barrette est
impopulaire selon leurs sondages a et b
en donnant à ces jeux vous attendent sur
une seule barrette après parce que ça
plus différent parce que lui folie folie
il ya pas d'allégations n'ya pas de
plainte c'est une autre histoire c'est
qu'il ne ré entre guillemets il entre
guillemets deux oui c'est ça le
respectait pas le territoire de madame
montpetit comme critique de la santé il
s'emmêlait mais je referme la porte sur
madame montpetit je vous donne 10
secondes est-ce que ce qu on allègue
s'étaient connus est ce que c'est
j'allais vous demandez ce que c'est vrai
vous le savez pas mais il faut qu'à une
enquête parce que là il faut qu'à se
défende ou sinon ça fait très longtemps
qui est des rumeurs qui courent
concernant le comportement de marie mon
petit à l'égard de ses collègues députés
à l'égard de ses employés politiques et
cela même avant a quant à lui été avec
philippe couillard même quand elle était
ministre c'est connu moi j'écris
vendredi et je le dis vendredi matin
j'ai publié vendredi dans la journée je
recevais beaucoup de témoignages de
député 2
de personnel politique alors ça se
confirme est de plus en plus du matin la
presse a publié et on s'attend peut-être
à ce qu'est d'autres choses qui sortent
cette semaine dont michel qu'est ce que
ça vous dit tout seul
d'abord cgem beau de voir un espèce des
feuillages il ya deux problèmes dans un
parti politique pour en remettre une
couche aujourd'hui parce que c'était
passé vendredi
ça c'est une chose deuxièmement on est
dans une époque où on ne tolère plus la
honte aux l'air plus de harcèlement
psychologique et s'il y avait plusieurs
planètes exclure madame montpetit du
caucus le temps qu'on voit ces plaintes
quant au fond était la chose à faire on
n'est plus dans le temps ou ont passé
l'épaule sur ces choses là évidemment
mais ça arrive dans un contexte avec ce
qui est arrivé vendredi avec le
north gilad par tweets interposés avec
le docteur barrette qui fait désordre
pas mal au parti libéral et ça ça lui a
valu la whey ses fans et
sur les allégations
il faudra quand même qui est un
processus où elle puisse se faire
entendre j'ai là peut-être vieux je le
mènerai quand même
peut-être pas vu le jeu et
il faut il faut tirer les choses au
clair on peut pas non plus et évidemment
moi je défends le travail de tous dans
la presse ce matin qui a été
certainement fait toutes les
vérifications nécessaires avant de
publier son article où il y avait des il
y avait des allégations sérieuses donc
je pense que ça ça a été pris en
considération mais je suis d'accord avec
vous que elle a quand même droit de se
défendre que le dit qu'elle ne ferait
donc attendons de voir mais polaire pour
la chef madame en glâne c'est certain
que comme michel on veut pas étirer la
douleur l'on va pas tirer sur le dial
chinon au ralenti et attendre d'âgés
et se faire accuser d'avoir réagi trop
tard c'était un peu comme je pense à
julie payette le quilliec s'est accroché
à son poste de gouverneur général
pendant très longtemps et c'est devenu
extrêmement douloureux donc ce sont des
ce sont des choses qu'on accepte plus
aujourd'hui l'intimidation le
harcèlement psychologique et plus de
tolérance pour ça alors je pense
qu'effectivement il fallait il fallait
prendre les devants rapidement su pour
madame anglade martin pour la pour
prenons l'exemple de monsieur bart est
donc je comprends qu'elle soit qui se
représente pas mais
dadis il a fait croire à ses bas c'est
ça la question c'est est-ce qu'elle va
passer au travers et là à ce moment ci
le
7h38 je peux pas répondre à cette
question là dans ce cas que c'est un
caucus très compliqué le caucus parce
qu'il y en a qui sont proches de sortie
y en a qui veulent bâtir c'est un parti
qui s'est pas mouillé il n'y a pas
vraiment de mission n'est pas juste un
clin d'oeil à deux clans trois quinquas
4 klein ils demandent humain il n'y a
pas de six mains dans ce parti là on
s'est passé quoi le parti libéral est
pas de cohésion idéologique on sait pas
où ça en vaut ce parti là et ça paraît
au caucus qui est assez désagréger et
courage et talent et sont notablement
sans doute il ya des mecs plus fort que
d'autres alors comment est ce que madame
anglade va ramener son caucus ensemble
est ce que va être capable d'avoir la
confiance de tous si elle perd la moitié
du caucus l'est dans une situation très
embêtant pour la suite des choses et il
y en a en coulisse lointaine qui
commence à penser un plan b
bon déjà je sais écouter pour les
citoyens pour ce qu'ils gagnent ça ils
n'ont pas beaucoup de façons de savoir
si le chef ou la chef de l'opposition
est quelqu'un qui va faire un bon
premier ministre cette façon qu'ils ont
c'est de regarder comment dirige son
parti et en particulier son aile
parlementaire parce que celle qu'on voit
le plus s'il a dû trop mal aile
parlementaire si on se dirait pas
capable de tenir ça ensemble ce monde là
est ce pas aussi gros que ce que seul
que ce libéral qu'est ce que vous en
à
la fin
les jeunes soldats
partis d'opposition ça fait ça fait la
peau de plusieurs chefs d'opposition
cette difficulté là avec un caucus ouais
faut dire qu objectivement une situation
même si elle était une magicienne de
vols vers le mans si populaire chez les
francophones au québec ses fans ils
s'ajoutent 9 disons son chemin il était
droit de temps cc clinquet la poêle à la
fois la route facile là on est à un an
des prochaines élections provinciales
publie des députés qui est qu'ils se
battre entre eux au lieu de devenir leur
force plus d'essayer de trouver une
façon de
2,2 fin août rien à la cac alors elle
donc on est mal parti et puis il va
falloir qu'il se passe quelque chose
rapidement parce que le lac a déjà
commencé à fourbir ses hommes se lancer
un peu campagne officieuse c'est pas
comme ça qu'ils vont voir arriver à
faire un contrepoids d'ailleurs j'ouvre
une parenthèse mais vous me faites
penser je devais pas en parler mais
michel avait créé un texte en fin de
semaine sur le le déluge de publicité
quand vous êtes campagne de la cac
j'aimerais quand même vous à entendre
martine michel la tuer on ouvre les
machines la publicité gouvernementale
un bon jeu et bonne chère oui tout est
sur la grille de départ c'est trois fois
plus d'argent que vous leur social pour
lequel ado complet un moment donné avec
des publics est un peu sociétal
n'inquiétait pas allez vous faire
vacciner là et l'on voit les conférences
de presse gouvernementale avec des
vedettes on voit les peler les annonces
sur la langue avec jean béliveau puis
avec jean lesage ont pas demandé à
fabien monsieur sarr jusque sache si
elles rouvrent il ne m'aime pas et tout
ça est assez des produits ces sociétés
quand c'est pas d'appui qui ai-je fait
sur la lame et une masse ribeiro puisque
c'est la cac alors on voit que lille
vont mettre des ressources
gouvernementales énorme dans leur
élection
alors
je serai un petit bol
à la malédiction des chefs élus par
altération tous les cercles sont tenus
par acclamation à un moment donné il ya
une partie du partic survire quant aux
autres diables pour ça de voir débouler
way martin un petit mot sur cet
instrument qu'est mme legault cas précis
le gouvernement de monsieur legault
c'est à dire la publicité
gouvernementale on le veut aussi lors du
discours inaugural
discours d'ouverture monsieur lebon
avait fait tout un vidéo donc on s'en
privera pas non le sait c'est
intéressant
ce dossier là parce qu'on est dans un
contexte d'élections à date fixe et
l'année électorale la question se pose
en tout le monde dépense davantage en
pré électorale et le parti qui est au
pouvoir a cet avantage parce qu'il peut
profiter de ces actions gouvernementales
pour faire de la propagande partisane
alors est-ce à me poser la question du
plafond de dépenses en année électorale
à partir du 1er janvier
2022 d'ailleurs le dge q pendant la
dernière élection avait documenté commun
chaque parti politique avait dépensé en
période pré électorale et je me rappelle
plus de chiffres mais si je me souviens
bien c'est à peu près 140 4 % de plus
dans l'année préélectorale en 2018
qu'avant quand on n'était pas en période
d'un an élections à date fixe alors
c'est ce qu'on voit présentement avec
les chiffres que comme chez nous
divulguer en fait cette semaine ça va
revenir le débat va sûrement se faire
sur cette question là entre temps
monsieur legault ça va la coop comme ce
trou qui est déjà à glasgow en écosse et
j'avais écrit en fin de semaine ses fans
et un trou sur le troisième est ce que
cet emprunt de saint-sever crise a joué
oui sur le troisième ligne et
d'oublier dont ça
quels sont les enjeux pour monsieur le
goût pour monsieur trudeau à cette coop
qui est énorme le
l'objectif on a parlé en début
d'émission est énorme c'est fanny je
compte vraiment oui mais c'est sûr que
l'enjeu est énorme parce qu'on doit se
fixer des cibles et puis en plus il faut
pas juste les fixer mais il faut les
atteindre et puis au québec on sait que
les cibles qu'on a fixés en ce moment
mais on a seulement 15 % du chemin de
parcouru pour s'y rendre en fait les
actions qu'on a comment annoncer en ce
moment vont permettre d'atteindre
seulement 40% de cet objectif là donc il
reste énormément à faire et c'est un peu
dans ce contexte l'objectif est le
troisième ligne c'est un projet à
enterrer monsieur leveaux lui même la
semaine dernière a concédé que c'était
pas en ligne avec les objectifs vert du
gouvernement
c'est un boulet qu'il traîne à glasgow
où il arrivait on va on ne va pas
comprendre quel est l'objectif de
construire ce tunnel là qui non
seulement n'est pas vert mais en plus
vous coûter une fortune et ne répondent
pas à un besoin et qui est qui qui est
vraiment évident j'entends les gens
québec des rebelles c'est bien une
éditorialiste de montréal qui disent à
la connaissez pas la circulation à
québec oui mais toutes les personnes à
qui j'ai parlé ce sont des personnes de
québec de nuit et elles sont il ya des
gens aussi la boxe qui sont pas en
faveur du projet mais je sais que je
suis montréal puis j'aime beaucoup
québec car c'est pas du tout parce que
je veux je suis contre la capitale mais
je pense qu'on va tous payés 10
milliards de dollars ou peut-être même
plus qui c'est à la fin et comme
contribuable on a quand même le droit de
se poser des questions sur ce projet qui
coûte très cher pique nique qui va être
polluée mais je pense martin que
monsieur legault lui-même commence à
s'approcher plus sûres monsieur s'était
pas dans le discours d'ouverture de
monsieur aucun regret quand même une
heure et quand c'est un projet de 10
milliards de dollars peut-être plus
généralement quand tu es prêt à dépenser
10 millions pour un projet tout en vente
ces enfants fait une publicité pour dire
que tu investit beaucoup alors s'il n'en
parle pas s'il ya des raisons à ça et
chaque semaine on essaie de le verdir
davantage alors on va voir qu'est ce qui
va et il va faire les prochaines heures
mais pour l'instant c'est mal barré je
vous envoie moins sur un monsieur
trudeau qui amène quand même à la coop
26 entre guillemets une vedette des
coptes monsieur guilbeault sominice de
l'environnement qu'ils à peu près tout
fait depuis 25 ans depuis 20 ans est-ce
que je traduis arrive là avec des cartes
à jouer
en essayant de faire oublier que le
canada quand même un des seuls pays le
seul pays du g7 heures ce qui a augmenté
ses émissions
la carte que je joue monsieur trudeau à
la main au sujet de broue anomalie est
de la virade mars et nous le canada
reconnaissons que on a été des beaux
parleurs des diffuseurs puis loeb a
essayé de changer ça c'est la seule
chose qui me deux choses importantes
dans lé contexte qui essaie d'envoyer
comme comme message
et il faut reconnaître effectivement que
le canada a joué beaucoup sur du vieux
garnier dans ces affaires le québec par
exemple
citer jaurès après problème à effet de
serre alors dit dont je suis le monde on
est les premiers sur 60 et en province
en amérique du nord we must à cause
d'hydroélectricité louis liste il y en a
un peu aussi un matériau il y avait un
peu manitoba par contre on a le même
problème qui est des grandes distances
univers qu'ils n'iront pas de sitôt dont
il va falloir toucher l avis des
citoyens pour commence pas dire on va
faire plus de 6 plus de ça dont on va
parler des voitures parler de ces choses
là et ça sera encore commencé ni au
québec ni au canada et vous toucher
quelque chose d'essentiel je pense dans
les deux trois prochaines années
stéphanie grammond c'est de les les
les élus devront dire aux gens il y aura
un coût à payer les deux voitures les
quartiers excentrés pas près des gares
on ne peut pas on peut pas non c'est sur
les voiliers va falloir qu'ils aient un
impact dans nos vies certains moments
parce que autrement on n'y arrivera pas
est à peu près clair et c'est pour ça
que les projets comme le troisième bien
qu'ils misent sur la voiture qui misent
sur l'étalement urbain et où on dit
finalement est ok on a de la congestion
alors qu'est ce qu'on fait on bâtit
encore plus c'était un peu comme
d'essayer de régler son problème
d'obésité en déboutonnant sa chemise ça
marche pour venir
vous fait rire il fait rire beaucoup
m'ont cédric et cameramen c'est toujours
bon
martin rapidement il va avoir une
annonce de monsieur legault concernant
alstom et le siège social à montréal et
à trop québec au québec est donc
peut-être des contrats bientôt on
comprend en fait le site si le transport
électrique et nova bus ou si alstom etc
c'est ça qu'on veut favoriser c'est ce
qu'on veut on veut on veut envoyer comme
message
à la coop que monsieur le gouvernail et
comme message c'est à dire que
l'électrification des transports c'est
important est que le québec va jouer un
rôle dans ce sens là et c'est ce qu'on
va vraiment brandir la batterie de
l'amérique du nord s'est pour la
première fois qu'on l'entend l'entente
depuis le début du mandat alors il
continue sur cette ligne
bon le gras grand patron d'air canada
vient donner un discours devant la
chambre de commerce de montréal
jusque là tout va bien
or on apprend qu'il sera uniquement
monsieur rousseau malgré son nom
francophone y parle pas vraiment
français michael rousseau en fait ils
parlent pas français du tout mais il
peut lire un texte stéphanie comment
vous avez réagi puis on le dit on le
confirme et là je la porte parole d'air
canada confirme aujourd'hui il va venir
à montréal je rappelle que le siège
social d'air canada c'est mon rien en
théorie
les grandes activités sont ailleurs même
siège social par la loi notamment rien
il va venir parler au québec à montréal
sans parler français votre réaction ça
fait mal aux besoins j'étais pas surpris
mais je ne sais pas que j'aie
l'approuvent non ils ont eu très très
bien mais air canada dans le passé ne
nous a jamais prouvé qu'ils aient qu'il
était un bon citoyen corporatif en
termes de langue française de
bilinguisme deux langues officielles
c'est c'est quelque chose qui suit
l'entreprise depuis longtemps
malheureusement ça ne fait que nous
donner la preuve que effectivement les
passagers est tout le monde avait raison
de se plaindre parce que le service en
français avoir des avions souvent été
critiqué et puis là mais c'est comme si
le président en personne
concrétise un peu et cristallise cette
impression là je pense que c'est c'est
bien malheureux puis ça ça arrive à un
point où justement on veut c'est de
renforcer
la la langue française dans les
institutions comme air canada comme
toutes les actions fédérales
très bien résumé michel c c'est charles
de commerce de montréal tu dois réagir
c'est elle qui doit dire et ça poda
l'urca notre tribune que le président
américan la compagnie établie à montréal
dans son siège social est ce que les
verts ce qu'est la chambre de commerce
de vancouver
l art un moment de laisser aussi à la
chambre de commerce de dire cette chose
là le symbole typ auto hall ou excusez
moi ouais martin c'est un an parce qu'on
peut penser qu'une entreprise comme air
canada d directeur de communication bien
payé pour conseiller ses dirigeants et
leur dire que la protection de la langue
ça fait débat au québec ça fait débat au
canada c'est sur à peu près toutes les
langues toutes les langues oui sans jeu
de mots est qu'effectivement
il devrait au moins six mairies symons a
été capable de baragouiner quelques 6 à
celui fondé ligue marc nombreuses
personnes en comme public deux trois
phrases puis pu les lire très bon
l'autre comme veolia difficule babinet
mme chan a été nommé il est papa avait
très bien
parti michel stefani toujours un plaisir
saluer la prochain merci
[Musique]